man i'll never forget uh my wife and i
went to this restaurant in new york
an indian restaurant
and we're literally sitting there
enjoying
this food
and we both cannot speak
it was so delicious we didn't speak for
an entire hour we're just literally
blown away at the incredible flavors of
all these spices so my favorite food is
indian food
but the problem is
it comes with a package it's very hard
to find indian food without this thing
called
sugar and out of all the countries
that use sugar
india is at the top the very top of the
list
india has a love affair
with sugar it's the largest consumer of
sugar in the world it's the second
largest producer of sugar in the world
behind brazil in fact they invented how
to refine sugar
over 2 000 years ago it's actually 2 372
years to be exact and so the whole
spreading of this sugar started from
india every traditional celebration
involves sweets religious social
gatherings festivals
weddings holidays you name it there's
going to be suites you know america they
have these indian specialty market
stores
you cannot find a product without
some type of sugar there's also two
types of traditional sugars that india
uses one is called kanseri which is kind
of a partially refined sugar with
some unrefined sugar together basically
you're adding some molasses to it so
they're going to add some vitamins and
then they have jaggery which is another
form of sugar which you're combining
either sugarcane sometimes with date
sugar or palm sugar
in india the average person consumes
8.7 kilograms of just the traditional
sugars every single year that's 19
pounds of sugar every single year and
we're only talking about these two
traditional types of sugar it's
incredible so unfortunately
this addiction i mean tradition
is so embedded in society that it's
going to be really hard to change i mean
in 2005
25 of the population was overweight and
obese
and then in 2013
that rose to roughly 64
of the entire population is overweight
or obese there's over 65 million people
who have type 2 diabetes in india that
is number two in the world behind china
sugar sweetened beverages from 1995 went
from two liters of this liquid sugar
candy type substance
to in 2015
an average person consumed 12 liters
of this liquid sugar this is on top of
all the other sugars i mean it's just
it's over the top and so the only change
is not going to come from
taxing people on eating sugar and
punishing them and forcing them to eat
healthy it's going to come from
you
you changing your diet
and you becoming healthy and having
people look at you and go wow you look
amazing i want to make that change so
honestly once you understand
how to make
these recipes with alternative sugars
it's not going to be that hard and the
taste with all those amazing spices and
aromas
could be virtually identical so there
are many different indian dishes that
you can make either without sugar or
with sugar alternatives and the cool
thing is the health benefits of all
these different herbs and spices
are amazing but when you add sugar it
kind of nullifies all the wonderful
benefits anti-inflammatory anti-cancer
anti-diabetic properties so let me first
talk about some keto friendly
indian dishes that you can start eating
immediately okay we have pioneer cheese
this is a traditional indian cottage
cheese made from either cow or buffalo
milk
it's great when you mix with spinach or
other types of foods i mean one cup you
have 22 grams of protein 29 grams of fat
which is great if you're on the keto
plan and only 3.6 grams net carb then we
have another dish called avl avl is a
south indian keto friendly dish it's
basically vegetable stew that is cooked
with seasonal vegetables like green
beans
drumsticks red pumpkin eggplant and
coconut milk and of course they add the
curry leaves to just make it awesome so
one serving is really only 1.7 grams of
net carbs
that's incredible then we have a masala
omelette you're cooking with butter
olive oil cheese you could probably put
some bacon in there if you wanted but
this is basically eggs onions tomatoes
with chili pepper turmeric coriander and
green chili quite delicious and very
keto friendly i think it's four carbs
per serving then you have the mutton
seek kebab now mutton could be either
lamb or goat but you're cooking this
with butter and onions and a blend of
amazing spices one serving is only three
grams of net carbs and what about
tandoori gobi these are delicious
cauliflower bites they use a very
delicious spice yogurt marinade grilled
in an air fryer or oven or even the
stovetop this is only 4.8 grams of net
carbs another one is chicken korma this
is a great dish where you're combining
chicken with certain vegetables with a
yogurt sauce and of course amazing
indian spices for that wonderful gravy
this one only has 4.8 grams of net carbs
then we have the indian coconut shrimp
curry it takes less than a half hour to
make it only has three grams of net
carbs and it's total keto so there's
many different low carb recipes that you
can make and still have that wonderful
delicious taste
yet without the sugar so i'm going to
put some amazing indian recipes down
below that my wife and i made but your
next step is to get on keto to help you
do that i created a very very simple
playlist of short videos to get started
right here